Halloween costumes can be expensive and
you know economy still not in great
shape most people on a tight budget so
we like to help out here with some money
saving Halloween costume ideas once
again is our prop master bill tall bill
take a large fish bowl put it on your
head
boom Matt Damon in the Martian let's go
with another tip
[Applause]
don't brush your hair or teeth for five
months boom Bernie Sanders the hair but
the teeth for God's sake here's another
one
turn on some colored lights start
dancing like your weird uncle boom Drake
[Applause]
take a bedsheet the pair of scissors
stab yourself boom
ghost take an adult-sized minion costume
put it on boom registered sex offender
[Applause]
take a french maid outfit add a mask of
your boss boom [ __ ] jackass
[Applause]
we're gonna churn the butter all right
we got a great shift of wets you always
churn the butter wrong what are you
talking about stirring the pot stirring
the pot water no burn the butter dish No
I hadn't thought that was in the all
right
wasn't that a great clip subscribe to my
youtube channel for an endless supply of
me
[Laughter]